DAVE: I feel alive when I
walk with a bow in my hands.
My senses are heightened.
I can smell the air.
I can feel the wind on my cheek.
Ah, here we go--
nice game trail.
[bow snap]
A grouse-- I had the shot on it.
And then my arrow
goes into this grouse,
and the bird flies
off with my arrow.
I start tracking it down,
and we got that grouse.
But it was obvious that
I had hurt this animal--
arrow broke its wing clean off.
I don't want to cause suffering
to any animal or being.
I don't hunt to kill.
I hunt to eat.
I tell myself, is
it better to kill
one large animal for many
meals or a bunch of small ones?
One deer-- that's the last game,
last life that I have to take.
I mean, I'm hurting
these animals.
[heavy sigh]
And it hurts my heart.
So what do I choose,
to be oblivious?
Do I choose to be a vegetarian?
Do I push the button?
[sigh]
Or do I keep killing?
I've killed five
grouse, a squirrel.
[sigh]
Man, that's a lot of pain.
That's a lot of pain.
[heavy sigh]
The hunter left, because
he couldn't hunt anymore.
[sigh]